the day after people around the world
led by the youth took to the streets
here young people taking over one of the
global halls of power this is the UN
Youth Summit but the most powerful
person was not here to speak the UN
secretary-general Antonio Guterres was
billed as the keynote listener and these
are among the speeches he heard these
negotiations on climate change policy
started in 1992 even before most of my
generation was born for over 25 years
and the emissions have only risin we
appreciate that youth are now at the
table where the discussions are being
held but our voices and our inputs must
be allowed to influence these decisions
yesterday millions of people across the
globe marched and demanded real climate
action especially young people we showed
that we we are united and that we young
people are unstoppable the UN is hoping
to leverage the People Power we've seen
in recent days led by the youth and
Greta tunberg ahead of a climate summit
of world leaders on Monday among those
who'll be there at the launch Chancellor
Merkel of Germany president Makarov of
France and Prime Minister Modi of India
but what about the two biggest emitters
well China will be represented by its
state councilor and foreign minister
Wang Yi and the US will president Trump
is in town but he won't be attending the
meeting in the u.s. system the longer
your title the more junior you are and
we're told the US delegation will be
headed by the principal Deputy Assistant
Secretary of State for oceans and
international environmental and
scientific affairs Marcia burnick at I'd
never heard of her before a clear snub
James BAE's al Jazeera at the United
Nations